I'm Jared Callum and this is a video
abstract for our recent manuscript
introducing a data-driven method to
identify dominant balance relations from
in physical systems and I'll talk about
what that means and go through one of
the main examples from our paper but
also just say that there's a lot more
detail in the paper and we also have
Jupiter notebooks up on github to
reproduce all the results and those
links will be in the video notes as well
but the main idea is that in many
complex systems local regions can be
well described by just a few terms of
the full governing equations and this is
something we've known intuitively for a
long time and have used a variety of
mathematical techniques to derive but
these usually rely on asymptotic
limiting conditions for instance
such-and-such parameter is much less
than 1 or much greater than 1 or
something like that so what we're
proposing is a method to augment the
classical approach using experimental or
numerical data and apply this
perspective on physical systems to more
general conditions so this quote from
Einstein is kind of a favorite among
people who do modeling and I think it
kind of gets to the core of Occam's
razor or the Pareto front or however you
like to think about these things our
models of the physical world should be
as simple as possible but no simpler and
of course one of Einstein's great
contributions was the theory of general
relativity which first told us that
Newtonian gravity was not the full
picture but I think it's sort of telling
that more than 50 years after we knew
that we landed on the moon and did it
without accounting for relativistic
effects we didn't need to Newton's law
was simpler and it worked for what we
needed and it really wasn't until we
started doing things like GPS that we
had to start accounting for Einstein's
theory
more recently dramatic improvements in
experimental and numerical methods have
given us unprecedented access to high
fidelity datasets describing extremely
complex physics from protein folding to
ocean circulation and even into the
Earth's magnetic core but
we have a detailed physical
understanding of many of these systems
in a lot of cases we also know that the
full first principles governing
equations aren't necessary throughout
the entire domain often the local
observed behavior can be described by a
balance between just a couple of
dominant processes so this is the
heuristic that we call dominant balance
and in some ways it's been a cornerstone
of the way that we think about modeling
physical systems classically we do this
with something like a an asymptotic
scaling analysis although as the systems
and conditions that we study become
increasingly complex it's not always
easy to do this with pen and paper and
if we can it's not necessarily obvious
where with the thing that we derive is
even going to be valid so our goal was
to develop a method that can use data to
extend this approach to non asymptotic
regimes we'd like to learn what the
important dynamics are in some region
and also equivalently learn what we can
ignore so to make this a little more
concrete let's walk through one of the
examples from the paper so this is a
canonical fluid dynamics problem called
a turbulent boundary layer and if you
haven't seen much fluid dynamics or
boundary layer theory I'll go through
kind of the classic approach in a
separate video but basically a boundary
layer is a region of a flow near a wall
where shear stresses lead to sharp
velocity gradients and things like
viscosity become much more important
understanding boundary layer Theory
turns out to be very important in a wide
range of applications including skin
friction drag on airplane wings and heat
transfer and atmospheric reentry
vehicles by the way what I'm showing
here is a video of a boundary layer in
transition to turbulence from the Johns
Hopkins turbulence database and this is
also the data set that we use in the
paper so because the this configuration
is so important boundary layer theory
was one of the great triumphs of 20th
century fluid dynamics and we actually
know quite a bit about the physics of
this flow including asymptotic behavior
dominant balance regimes and various
scaling laws
so although turbulence is famously
unsteady and chaotic in a lot of cases
we're really only interested in average
quantities so if we take the
instantaneous flow field and decompose
it into mean and fluctuating terms we
get what's called the Reynolds average
navier-stokes equations and what I'm
showing here is the momentum equation
for the downstream X component and so
the way I wrote it here we have six
terms including mean flow advection
pressure gradient viscosity and these
Reynolds stresses which are related to
turbulent momentum transport but
although we know from first principles
in this case momentum conservation that
all of these terms have to be in the
equation we also know that they're not
all equally important everywhere and
I'll walk through our analysis on this
case but in the end we'll find that we
can reproduce the standard results that
you'd get from a scaling analysis so in
this case we can actually visualize the
dominant balance pretty easily by just
plotting the value of the terms across
the domain so this is the stream-wise
component of mean flow advection and now
the instantaneous fields have been
averaged in time and in the span-wise
direction which is homogeneous so we can
repeat this for the other five terms in
the equation and we can immediately see
that although most of these terms are
important somewhere in the field they're
not all important everywhere and usually
the local description involves a balance
between just a couple of terms so for
instance in a lot of the turbulent part
of the layer this wall normal Reynolds
stress is pretty significant but it's
balanced out pretty evenly by the mean
flow advection and then there's this
thin viscous layer near the wall which
is also balanced by the Reynolds stress
and so these are well known regions of
the turbulent boundary layer that are
usually called the inertial and viscous
sub layer we could also think about
visualizing this by taking each point in
the discretized domain and doing a six
dimensional scatter plot where each of
the terms in the governing equation
corresponds to one of the
coordinates and so we'll call this the
equation space representation of the
field and notice that dominant balance
is a very natural geometric
interpretation in this space so if we
had a perfect balance between viscosity
and Reynolds stress in the viscous sub
layer we'd see that all of the points
from the viscous sub layer fall on a
perfect line between those two and all
the other coordinates would be zero in
general dominant balance is going to
show up in the equation space as an
approximate local restriction to some
subspace of the in this case sixth
dimensional equation space and it might
be worth pausing here a second to think
about this because this is really the
core of what we're doing in this paper
this geometric perspective on dominant
balance is what lets us use very simple
machine learning tools to identify the
dominant local physics throughout the
domain so now that we have our equation
space representation of the field we can
think about using unsupervised learning
methods to look for sets of points with
variants in distinct directions so we
could imagine using any number of
algorithms to do this but we just choose
some simple ones that are available off
the shelf from something like
scikit-learn and I'm gonna totally skip
over the details of how this works but
again it's all in the paper and the code
that's available online basically the
idea is we're looking for clusters of
points that are approximately restricted
to some subspace and then we can
interpret the active directions of that
subspace as the active terms in that
cluster so I want to make the point here
that this method is kind of
intrinsically interpretable because this
equation space representation is
fundamentally linked to the governing
equation so any analysis that we do in
this space has a clear interpretation in
terms of the underlying physics and we
can go through and think about what each
of these balance relations actually
means so for the boundary layer now we
have our clusters and our balance
relations and then we can take each
point in the equation space and just map
back to the original domain and I'll
also say here that we
do anything to enforce that these points
are actually near each other in the
original domain although if you think
about how this works and for a smooth
field it sort of makes sense that they
would be but now we can actually go
through and look at what each of these
balance relations are in terms of a well
known boundary layer physics so now we
can see the laminar inflow the inertial
and viscous sub layer 's and so on
so for instance this is kind of just a
standard sketch of the breakdown of a
turbulent transitional boundary layer
but now we can actually start from data
and see where exactly each of these
things are valid we can also check that
the segmentation of our domain is
consistent with known boundary layer
scaling so for instance the inertial sub
layer is known to scale the the width of
this thing is known to scale with X to
the 4/5 and if we just take the post
transitional y coordinate here and fit
it to a power law we get X to the point
8 1 which is pretty nice agreement okay
but again so far all we've done here is
relearn something that we've been able
to do by hand for about a hundred years
so in order for this to be interesting
we need to be able to apply it to
systems where the asymptotics aren't so
clear-cut
so in the paper we look at a wide range
of physical examples for instance we
look at optical pulse propagation in a
certain kind of fiber optic cable and we
find that most of the field can be
described pretty well by linear
dispersion relations except for this
very energetic soliton that needs a
nonlinear Schrodinger type dominant
balance we also look at reanalysis data
for the surface currents in the Gulf of
Mexico and we identify regions of
approximate geostrophic balance
including the southern end of the Gulf
Stream here and finally we look at a
generalized hodgkin-huxley type model of
an intrinsically bursting neuron and
this one is a little bit different
because it's an ordinary differential
equation that's basically on a multi
scale limit cycle but we are able to
identify dominant balance relations that
are consist
than with the known bio physics of
spiking neurons so we have this slow
background process driven by calcium
currents but then during the bursts of
spikes the dynamics are dominated by the
kind of standard sodium potassium
mechanisms that hodgkin-huxley described
so in all these systems were able to
identify dominant balance regimes that
are consistent with either the standard
asymptotic results or our qualitative
understanding of the physics and again
the key idea here is the equation space
representation this geometric
perspective on dominant balance lets us
use very simple off-the-shelf machine
learning methods to identify the
dominant local physics so I'd like to
acknowledge our supporters and everyone
who worked on the open datasets and
tools that we use to do this analysis
and again there's much more detail
available in the links including the
classic analysis details on the method
including hyper parameter tuning
uncertainty analysis for assignment to a
balance relation and Jupiter notebooks
to reproduce all of the results here so
thanks for checking this out and I hope
this turns out to be useful for you